let's get reaction now from two
prominent voices on either side of the
debate Jena Miller was the lead claimant
in the legal challenge against the
government which resulted in the Supreme
Court ruling that article 50 couldn't be
triggered without a parliamentary vote
and Tim Martin is the founder and
chairman of JD Wetherspoon he campaigned
ahead of the referendum for Britain to
leave the EU Jena let me start with you
it's happening is your fight over well
I'm pleased that the trigger has been
done along the lines of a constitutional
requirements but though the battles not
over because I will be upholding the
judgement in my case which is that
Parliament has to be involved all the
way through the process and exiting
whenever it is that it's going to
diminish or remove individuals rights
even if that means that Parliament votes
down any deal that ariza may brings back
if Parliament has a meaningful vote and
actually doesn't stop there is no need
for me to step up if however it
rubber-stamps and doesn't have a proper
debate then that's a whole nother issue
but I mean arguably if it's doing its
job right and it's it sees a deal that
ariza may come up with it it doesn't
like then it should vote it down what it
should do but if all they're offered is
a vote between a bad deal and no deal
that's not a meaningful vote and that
actually would not satisfy the judgment
in my case is no deal better than about
deal I don't think that that's actually
a choice I think it's like you can shoot
yourself in the foot with an arrow or a
gun I don't see how that's a choice in
any way Tim are you holding an arrow or
a gun oh it's difficult when you get
into the constitutional legal issues I
think the country voted to leave and and
that's the key thing I actually think we
may well be better with no deal because
everyone seems to be frantic for a deal
and the great danger anyone who runs a
business knows this or buys a house or a
car if you say you're desperate for a
deal you're likely not not to get a good
one
with no deal with America nor does the
EU India China the biggest economies in
the world and we do very well in our
trade with those countries so I would
say perfectly happy to
no deal at all I think that might be
best for us and JD Wetherspoon could
live with that if the UK was trading on
WTO terms WTO terms and would still go
for a pint after work yeah what about I
mean on the migrant question you're
quite interesting because a lot of
people not only campaigners wanted
control of the borders you're slightly
unusual in that you employ lots of EU
migrants and you want them to stay here
post brexit employs a relatively small
number it's around three or four percent
of our workforce excellent workers
excellent people done a great job I
think to have a successful economy that
population needs to rise over the years
there's a low birth rate in the UK and I
think we benefit from emigration in the
same way as America has New Zealand
Australia Singapore but it has to be
controlled by the UK government the the
EU system has brought immigration into
disrepute and frightened people because
people you haven't elected are allowing
old countries access presumably you
wouldn't disagree the work that you know
what you well I am astounded at the
naivety that we can do trade deals when
we haven't left actually we have to
negotiate our exit from the EU before we
even look at negotiating a free trade
deal with any other country because our
existing trade deals actually exist but
through our membership of the EU to say
that we could be talking to China all
these other countries we actually have
to leave first then we negotiate our
free trade deals and that negotiation
that exit is not going to take two years
so the reality of the situation is we
have to get one done before we can start
the next leg of the race two gloomy far
two gloomy they use be unable to do
trade deals with the biggest economies
in the world it's broadly speaking only
done trade deals with smaller economies
because ik everyone can't agree even
with Canada quite a small country 5% of
the population of the EU it was hell to
arrange a deal so don't don't get your
hopes up over a deal we don't need one
we got a great big trade surplus with
America they drink our whiskey they buy
our cars they buy lots of other stuff
don't get too fixated on a tray
and yet it was very interesting today
that in Teresa maids letter she's
clearly indicating that she's hoping for
more than just WTO terms well probably
if you could snap your fingers and have
a free trade deal with the rest of the
world it might be it might be good but
that's what the World Trade Organization
is designed to cover and we can scrap
all tariffs if we want to anyway which
is what a lot of the economists for
brexit say prices will go down seven or
eight percent government tax will
probably go up we'll all be better off
fantastic just scrap the tariffs
unilaterally I mean I love the optimism
that has no basis in reality because the
legal requirements I'm sorry but there
are requirements of how you do that if
not why did we join why are we going
through this process why actually as use
the question you could have just left
the day after actually as a law a
certain din my case the government
couldn't just do that on its own you
can't leave there is a process to
leaving and there's a process to joining
the double here but after we've left yes
but how long is that going to take well
we leave in two years if you think we
will then you're being very optimistic
because I don't think it'll be two years
but I mean you Jeanne mentioned the
process there I mean Michele Barnea is
very clear before we even start
discussing any future relationship with
between the EU and the UK we've got to
sort out a bill for leaving I mean
that's where process really gets the
better of common sense do I look in any
divorce it comes down to haggling about
money and that's actually what we're
going to end up with haggling about
money before any serious negotiations
start and the EU says you know nothing
is agreed until everything is agreed
that's the old EU saying and I can see
that that's what they're going to stick
to but however I hope there isn't a sort
of a tit-for-tat and there is a
completely different mood as we go
forward from both sides well do you
think the mood is going to change now
that article 50 has been triggered is
the relationship between levers and
remainders going to alter I think we
have to stop going on about those terms
we're not actually levers or remain as
you know introduces it we're actually
all levers now and that's the point it's
about getting rid of the emotion and
looking at how we go pal go forward in
this process because the bottom line has
got to be what is best for Britain that
the only thing that matters now you go
along with that Tim what is best for
Britain and we trade with 93% of the
world mostly without trading agreements
I think we'll do very well
all right very very briefly tibial for
Northern Ireland's do you think we're
going to get a hot border no I don't
think we will I think common sense will
prevail and we'll be able to work
something out the Irish are famous for
being able to work out consensual Beals
Sir Martin Gina Miller thanks both